hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a Japanese comedy fantasy
film called assassination classroom
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie opens up as an unknown person
destroys 70 of the Moon with a single
explosion because of the catastrophe the
world goes into a state of utter Panic
the Japanese military is the first one
to react and when they reach a suspected
Hideout a mysterious tentacled being
eliminates them one by one the movie
then shifts to kunigi gaoka high school
where the principal is making a major
announcement he says that from now on
the worst students in the school I.E
class 3E will relocate to a Mountainside
Cottage so that they cannot disturb the
others it is then revealed that the 3E
students are often mocked and treated as
undesirables because of their poor
grades just go to the mountains or
something you freaking idiots the
protagonist Nagisa shiyota is also a
student of the same class but he doesn't
mind being taught separately he simply
wants to finish high school and get a
job as soon as he can later Nagisa along
with his classmates go to their new
classroom only to be shocked at finding
out who their new teacher is it is none
other than Koro Sensei the tentacled
mutant creature that apparently is
responsible for the moon's destruction
here it is revealed that the entire
class is actually designed by the
Japanese government in their attempt to
kill korosensei the tentacled monster is
promised to eviscerate Earth in exactly
a year however he is giving the
government a chance to assassinate him
as part of the deal korosensei will get
to teach the students for a year and
they can attack him as much as they can
with special knives and pellets
korosensei will not retaliate he will
just block the attacks and make sure
that the students are safe so now the
fate of the world is in the hands of the
students they have to somehow find a way
to kill korosensei before they graduate
as of now they have no combat skills so
they are assisted by a
government-affiliated agent tadayomi
karasuma when the class begins Karo
Sensei tells the students that he just
signed a management contract with the
school to teach the students for a year
he has promised not to harm them but the
students can attempt to kill him the one
who succeeds will be awarded 10 million
yen the teaching assistant karasuma adds
that korosensei is very fast in speed
and that the students might not be able
to challenge him he reminds them that
they have to plan extraordinarily to
succeed in their goals he also
demonstrates some fighting skills with
his knives and guns however Koro Sensei
effortlessly grabs the knife from
karasuma and cuts one of his tentacles
the creature feels no pain whatsoever
and in this instance it becomes apparent
that Koro Sensei is extremely Mighty
additionally he has the ability to
regenerate his body parts but the more
time it takes for him to regenerate the
more his speed will decrease this is the
only apparent weakness he has the next
day students begin their duty to kill
their new teacher they use their own
sets of guns and Target him with all
their might however korosensei is so
fast that he Dodges all of the bullets
without even breaking a sweat all this
while Nagisa notes his teacher's mood in
hopes of observing his emotions and
pouncing at the right moment some of the
bullies notice him and insist that he
work with them instead of planning the
murder alone Nagisa complies and after a
bit of planning he fearfully approaches
Koro Sensei with a knife in hand as
expected the latter catches wind of the
attack and repels it easily however
Nagisa has a backup plan too he abruptly
hugs Cora Sensei and this is when the
alien realizes that the boy is in
possession of explosive materials the
very next second a loud explosion
startles the class the bullies cheer in
Victory thinking that they killed the
alien and thus will be awarded the prize
money they don't even go to check if
their friend is all right but suddenly
when the dust clears the bullies notice
a mysterious coating that Shield Nagisa
from the explosives moreover the alien
is surprisingly alive and well he jumped
onto the ceiling in a fraction of a
second but not before saving Nagisa from
the danger the alien cheerfully reveals
that he sheds his skin every year just
like a snake this thing is goddamn
terrifying however his mood soon changes
Toro sends a gross Furious okay scarier
now as he tells the students that they
broke their contract agreement the
students weren't allowed to use any
explosives to kill him they were only to
use guns today they almost got one of
their friends killed the alien decides
to excuse the students this time but if
they are to repeat the same mistake once
more he will surely harm their family
members the following day when the alien
is outside a student manages to distract
him and put him in a net she then points
her gun at him but isn't able to get a
proper shot as Koro Sensei moves at full
speed even though he's trapped in a net
just then a new student arrives at the
scene he is karma akabane a grade a
student who has recently come out of his
suspension Karma was apparently punished
for instigating a fight but in reality
he was just protecting his friend from a
bunch of bullies now despite being a
brilliant student he is forced to study
in the notorious class 3E in the next
scene Karma introduces himself to
everyone and proposes to shake hands
with his teacher obliging to the request
Coro Sensei extends his tentacles but as
soon soon as he does so he feels a sharp
pain Karma then reveals that he had some
blades pasted on his palm which caused
the wound with this he is the first
student who is able to harm the alien as
time passes by Karma attempts to kill
the alien teacher in various ways sadly
none of his techniques work out one day
as karma is sitting alone Nagisa
approaches him and the two have a
personal chat Karma reveals that he
doesn't care about the award money he
just wants to finish off korosensei and
rid the world from his Terror just then
the alien also arrives at the scene
Karma asks him if he is a good teacher
who supports his students when they are
in trouble or a bad teacher who never
cares about them saying this he jumps
off a cliff while holding a gun in his
hands Karma's plan is simple he knows
that korosensei will try to save him and
for that he will have to slow down this
will give Karma the perfect chance to
shoot him in the head and finish him off
once and for all badass however to his
dismay the clever alien quickly rushes
down changes his form into a web and
saves karma from an apparent death
following this we are taken to a
military meeting it has been two months
since Koro sensei's attack on the moon
with increasing pressure several
countries have been launching nuclear
missiles on Japan to destroy Koro Sensei
however for some reason the alien
himself has been taking care of the
missiles and saving the country from any
potential blast the assistant teacher
karasuma who is also in the meeting
tells his chief that they will have to
send another student to class 3E since
the current ones aren't able to kill
okoro Sensei the next day we are
introduced to ritsu an AI box displaying
the form of a girl she is loaded with
powerful weapons that are specially
designed to kill korosensei while the
alien teacher begins his class with
other students ritsu locks her Target
and immediately begins firing
unsurprisingly korosensei manages to
save himself but the other students are
scared to death as they hide under
tables to protect themselves when
everything is settled the students
confront ritsu and quickly Tire with
metal chains as she is a threat to
everyone in the later korosensei
approaches ritsu and explains that her
wrath is what made the situation
escalate quickly she should have worked
with the other students to kill him
therefore ritsu transforms into an
application and gets herself downloaded
into every student's mobile phone she
also shares a message of unity which
helps her gain the acceptance and Trust
of her fellow students in the next scene
another new student joins class 3E his
name is etona hori Bay a tiny
blonde-haired boy who claims to be the
blood brother of Koro Sensei to
everyone's surprise he can also unleash
Tentacles from his body okay I'm getting
pumped his trainer who is in a cloaked
uniform informs the class that etona has
exceptional fighting skills he is so
deadly that he can even finish off Koro
Sensei the latter takes this as a
challenge so he decides to fight the boy
shortly after amidst loud cheers from
the students the fight between Koro
Sensei and etona Begins the alien
teacher is distressed to see that the
student has the same tentacles as him he
believes that etona is one of his
distant family members so he decides to
go easy but the boy takes advantage of
this and manages to wound him enraged
Koro Sensei quickly regains his
composure and unleashes a powerful
strike which sends etona out of the
classroom hence defeating him all the
students are ecstatic to see him win and
they congratulate him happily in this
way despite being their ultimate Target
Koro Sensei is able to bond with class
3E who in turn regard him as their
indispensable teacher talk about stock
doe home syndrome one day karasuma's
position as an assistant teacher is
briefly replaced by his rival Akira
takayoka who is very tough on students
in one of his sessions a student says
that she cannot train anymore she's very
tired hearing this Akira becomes Furious
and attempts to assault her damn Akira
chill thankfully karasuma arrives just
in time to stop him the two Rivals
berate each other for a while and Akira
promises that he will leave the school
the only catch is that one of the class
3E students will have to touch him with
a knife karasuma accepts The Challenge
and he decides to send out Nagisa all
the students also gather around and
watch nervously they believe that Nagisa
is no match for the skillful teacher
however to their surprise the quiet boy
cleverly distracts Akira with a devious
smile and then pounces on him with the
knife thereby winning the challenge one
day it suddenly starts raining and
Nagisa notices that Karo Sensei is
acting a little different today he
observes that the alien Teacher's Body
has also begun to swell because of the
rain this makes Nagisa realize that Koro
Sensei is allergic to water before the
final socoro Sensei promises that the
top scorers of the five academic
subjects chemistry English home
economics Japanese and maths will be
awarded the chance to cut his
rubber-like tentacles which will greatly
slow him hearing this the students are
pleased as it will surely make their
assassination attempts a lot easier in
the following days korosensei helps the
students with their studies and also
takes them to space and shows them
around the world when the results for
the finals are out a total of six
students are able to top the finals as
two of them get the same marks in
homemade economics however korosensei is
not bothered a bit he just wants some
challenge as he is starting to get bored
now on the day when he is supposed to be
assassinated class 3 e manages to bind
korosensei thanks to nagisa's
observation of his weakness water they
shoot down his tentacles one by one
however when they are about to land the
final shot korosensei causes an
explosion when the dust clears it is
revealed that he has transformed himself
into an impenetrable ball as the
students watch in shock suddenly half of
them start dropping unconscious a
vengeful Akira then arrives there and
reveals that he was the one who poisoned
the students he is accompanied by the
blonde boy etona who turns out to be his
disciple fortunately before things can
escalate Nagisa and Karma team up and
incapacitate etona by luring him into
open rain and subsequently cutting his
tentacles however they are alerted by
ritsu that Akira has kidnapped one of
their classmates he is now threatening
to kill her unless Coro Sensei is handed
over but this time class 3E is having
none of with a simple trick they turn
the tables around and defeat Akira
effortlessly they then angrily spill mud
all over him while cursing at him for
being a bad teacher on the other hand
the AI ritsu creates antidotes for the
students and nurses them back to health
shortly after the government officials
arrive at the school seeing that
korosensei is vulnerable they take him
and proceed to do a public execution in
front of his grieving students the alien
teacher who is still in the form of a
ball is Chained in a room which is
inside a very concrete Dome full of
explosives as the students watch the
live execution Koro Sensei delivers his
last goodbye message he conveys that he
is grateful his students were able to
defeat him this shows that they are
strong and eligible enough to fend for
themselves this achievement is more than
enough for a teacher like him to be
happy moments after there is an
explosion and as the military cheers for
their success the students start weeping
as they have lost their favorite teacher
Nagisa is the one affected the most and
as he cries profusely someone passes a
napkin from behind it is none other than
Koro Sensei who somehow survived the
attempted killing seeing him alive the
government ultimately gives up on their
project and lets him continue teaching
class 3E for the next term the movie
ends as the blonde little boy etona also
enrolls in the same class the world is
doomed subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching